full of the meanest lyrics about a
celebrity since Taylor Swift's last
album
has the same reaction to Haley's gagging
I was okay
then let's break it all down we know
Taylor Swift is one of Selena's ride or
dies going on over a decade of close
friendship oh no
my bestie
is a bad
so it's no surprise Selena's coming to
taste defense in the wake of a resurface
drop the mic clip from 2017.
job no more
the series was hosted by Method Man and
Haley Baldwin who's better known these
days with the last name of her husband
and Selena's ex Justin Bieber on drop
the Mike Hollywood's top Stars Face-Off
in a one-on-one rat battle full of the
meanest lyrics about a celebrity since
Taylor Swift's last album
it's blowing up on Tick Tock so much so
it made its way to Selena's fyp where
she wasted no time giving her two cents
in the comments writing so sorry my best
friend is and continues to be one of the
best in the game I'm at that age where I
feel like that's what matters is making
sure I'm healthy and people are happy
that I love the only murders in the
building Stars been playing defense all
week on Wednesday Selena found herself
in a rumored Feud with Haley and Kylie
Jenner rumor being the key word I
accidentally laminated my brows too much
all it took was this post from Selena
followed by Kylie snaps of her and
Haley's eyebrows and the drama popped
off like I would love my true fans to
know like all my personal stuff the
beauty Mogul quickly stepped in telling
fans this is reaching no shade towards
Selena ever and I didn't see her eyebrow
posts you guys are making something out
of nothing this is silly Selena also
swooped in to clear the air writing
agreed Kylie Jenner it's all unnecessary
I'm a fan of Kylie on social media it's
as much as it's a blessing and it's fun
it it can really tear people down and I
always hope that the people I'm involved
with or support me can just kind of
spread love within that I know it's been
a week of rumor Patrol cells never too
busy to spread that message of kindness
to her fans disgusting despicable
behavior from the nepo babies nepo
babies possibly a reference to Haley
who's got a famous dad Stephen Baldwin
and Uncle Alec Baldwin Selena clearly
moved by the fans video wrote I love you
like can you imagine going through a
breakup so publicly with a guy that you
were in love with for like seven years
and then like two months later he just
like marry someone and then you have
like a chronic illness honestly like
kudos to her for being so brave and so
public and she slid into the comments
here to admit all the love made me cry
I'm very honest though in general
meanwhile Selena also reminding Us girl
can slay
check out this Sizzle and snap which
cell previously deleted because she
thought it was maybe too much for the
gram too much with you Selena there's no
such thing I think my advice is to not
be afraid
[Music]